maman
je crois que je sais qu'il y a ta fille
elle était dans une secte pour l'amour
de Dieu tu crois vraiment que c'est une
femme est fiable j'ai perdu ma femme
j'ai perdu ma fille si tu crois que les
autorités
tu dois la retrouver toi-même
je veux voir ma fille elle était en vie
il y a deux semaines
[Musique]
que tout ce qu'on peut imaginer
dans ton Église avec cet accoutrement
et lui qui sait un nouveau monde de la
famille tu es très dis-moi tout de suite
ce que tu sais
le diable ce n'est qu'un concept c'est
de la foutue magie noire
tout le monde finit par choisir un camp
cette pourriture t'a fait tout en lavage
de cerveau
tu as envie de mourir où est ma fille
[Musique]
dans l'autre monde
ça tient plus tu crois que j'ai pas vu
clair dans ton petit jeu je sais
pourquoi tu es ici
tu l'es tous d'accord
je suis ma propre liberté
de moi
regarde ça c'est ça Dieu est mon coyote
[Musique]